you're winning this award because you
obviously deserve it but I think the
icing on the cake is that you got to
make it a family night so how does it
feel to be honored and how does it feel
to have Sophia here with oh my God I'm
so honored that my entire family is here
I have a lot of family members the
entire family is just like a little
piece of their family you know they all
wanted to come but they're just a little
if you take a lot of things it's like
400 people yeah
and also it's very special for me that
you know my cousin was able to do this
and I'm feeling very honored I'm very
happy about it yeah yeah Sofia was
Mariana always the beauty Guru in the
family I mean are you texting her all
the time asking her questions not at the
beginning when she was young she was
kind of like a tomboy and then she went
to medical school and we never thought
that she was gonna go into that area but
then she became kind of like obsessed it
became Beauty and everything that had to
do with you know making women and people
not only women because she also does a
man feel their best became like an
obsession with her and then one time she
told me about this idea that she had
about the villa and how to make it
private for not just for celebrities but
for people in general that just wanted
to do their things and not you know not
be bothered I thought it was genius so
here we are and you know I think it's
well deserved
the celebration plans for tonight look
like how do you guys turn up
until what time we're gonna we're gonna
be tonight where are we going last night
was until three in the morning and it
was just because we were preparing for
tonight so I don't even know what I mean
I'm ready
I'll take care of her with an IV maybe
tomorrow with an IV perfect perfect have
you ever tried that by the way yes
Mariana has done a lot of IBS because
you know I travel a lot and I work a lot
and you know the weather in La doesn't
help either and I'm 50 sorry time you
know it's like Mariah you know it's
great also for hangovers it's great
you rather for beauty usually for beauty
yeah you are clearly the secret weapon
here you are you're so beautiful and so
Flawless you just mentioned you're 50.
what do you want to accomplish in this
next decade of life oh I've accomplished
everything I just want to you know try
to stay alive yeah healthy yeah
thank you and your business Endeavors
what does your Empire look like
my Empire I will not call it an Empire I
just want to be happy and I enjoy
whatever I do and helping people out
foreign